ah
the Kodak Theatre at Hollywood and
Highland welcome to the 75th Academy
Awards
ladies and gentlemen your host for this
evening Steve Martin
well I'm glad they cut back on all the
glitz
you probably noticed there was no fancy
red carpet tonight that'll send them a
message by the way the proceeds from
tonight's Oscar telecast and I think
this is so great will be divvied up
amongst now I am so excited to be back I
didn't host the show last year because I
was how do you say it not asked but
everybody has been so supportive of my
hosting this year except of course
France and Germany
now the Oscars are being broadcast for
the first time in high-definition
television so I'd like to say a big
hello to the three guys watching at
Circuit City
hey writers directors actors if we're
stuck here tonight and we run out of
food that's the order of whom we eat
down
before we go any further I have a
confession to make
just before I came out here I licked all
the Oscars
now this is the 75th anniversary of the
Oscars the very first Academy Awards was
held 75 years ago right across the
street at the Roosevelt Hotel and on
your way out
take a look you just go outside across
Hollywood Boulevard make a right at the
hooker oh excuse me pretty woman
and you'll see the location of the very
first Oscars in 1929 all the big stars
were there and of course Joan Rivers was
outside
and many great stars are here tonight
Olivia de Havilland is here we have Kirk
Douglas and Margaret O'Brien Mickey
Rooney is here now
not it not a lot of people know this but
Mickey Rooney is the same age as the
earth
at at one point Mickey Rooney was the
biggest box-office star in all the 38
states Mickey I salute you where are you
Mickey hey hey
Mickey
micki I'm sorry we couldn't get you a
better seat but then diesel is here oh
good Mickey is heckling me now today's
movie stars make millions of dollars but
Mickey Rooney was paid in shiny beads
Barbra Streisand is here who's just here
tonight
he's just here tonight to enjoy the show
and direct
and there's nicole kidman now here's it
interesting fact about nicole kidman not
a lot of people know this nicole kidman
has worn a fake nose in every movie
she's ever made except the hours looking
good Nicole Halle Berry is here and
notice I am standing exactly twenty-two
feet away from Halle Berry in compliance
with the court order tonight Jack
Nicholson and Meryl Streep made Oscar
history it was
it was backstage and it wasn't pretty
it's a big year for Jack he also got in
a hot tub with Kathy Bates but hey who
hasn't
there was a lot of big movies this year
now I love Lord of the Rings that was a
great download sorry theatrical
experience now another big movie Chicago
now I'm just being honest here
Miramax stopped at nothing to make sure
Chicago was nominated now here's what
they did and you tell me if you think
this is fair they made a really good
movie that everybody likes
well if you're going to do that now I
don't like the Oscar stage being used
for promotion one year I watched Billy
Crystal ride out here on a horse just to
promote his movie city slickers and I
was so mad it just made me want to start
bringing down the house
well thank you for mentioning it and I
loved working with Queen Latifah there
she is
Queen Latifah or as I like to call her
sequel money
you know I've just realized that hosting
the Oscars for the second time is like
making love to a woman for the second
time I guess
now there were smaller movies to this
year there was a movie called secretary
about a woman who was humiliated by her
boss his spanked and has to crawl on her
knees and carry manila folders in her
teeth and they say there are no parts
for women movie jackass was out this
year which in my opinion was the worst
Hollywood adaptation yet of Jane Austen
Afghanistan submitted a film this year
my big fat skinny raggedy-ass one Hunter
ste camel now there are a lot of
cutbacks this year in the movie industry
lots of layoffs and now they're talking
about reducing actors salaries for God's
sake are we insane and things are
financially tough all over so right now
you should do what Tom Cruise does at
the end of each week he takes a million
dollars and he just puts it away like
it's not even there
whether it's been a good week or a bad
week and then at the end of the year
you've got a little cushion oh sorry
I thought I saw a non-celebrity
ah roman polanski is here get up now
this year some people in Hollywood were
insulted by the use of the term gay
mafia and I say to them well they seem
to be extremely upset I say to them hey
fellas don't get your thongs in a knot I
understand now that throwing a phone in
the middle of a joke is a bad idea it
was planned I thought it was funny now I
use the term gay mafia last week in the
next morning I woke up and there was a
poodle head in my bed
you know looking at this audience
tonight seeing so many familiar faces
acknowledging your talent seeing people
who have meant so much to the world it
just makes me wonder for a minute what
is a movie star
Movistar as many things they can be tall
short thin or skinny
they can be Democrats
or skinny
Movistar can be young middle-aged or old
we worship them we idolize them and yes
sometimes we're annoyed with them like
when they shoot their wives
but movie stars know the public is
watching so they always try to look
their best
they can be any sex race or religion
sometimes all in one weekend they can be
straight or gay
movie stars crave publicity but have the
decency not to brag if they've slept
with me
well you know the list can go on forever
but we do have to get on with the 75th
anniversary of the Oscars remember there
are no losers here tonight but we're
about to change all that I should tell
you that if you are a winner and your
speech goes on too long first you'll see
flashing lights and then the band will
start to play and then you'll feel
something stick in your neck and I would
suggest that you walk toward the light
to your loved ones who are saying come
you big winner you now by the way if
you'd like a transcript of tonight's
show simply write down every word we say